if you want to know what the key to
happiness is it's struggle this is the
thing that I'm not sure about I saw
things that that I don't think most
people in the UK or the the us see I
wanted to understand money I didn't come
from it but I thought maybe if I
understand money then I could understand
this thing called power and I could help
more people have it but I could also
protect myself too I buy bar and
businesses and what I mean by that is
that I buy mom and pop businesses all
around the US and then I talk about it
on the internet I've found it to be a
huge benefit that I'm a woman in the
workplace one of my mentors told me
something that I thought was kind of
true he's like the men that work with
you typically either want to bother you
friend you or they want to you